oi meu nome é joão monteiro murta eu
tenho 19 anos de idade eu vou falar pra
vocês que pequenas ações de cada um de
nós pode mudar meio ambiente também vai
falar sobre o exemplo de uma inovação
que promete eliminar a poluição dos
mares com o problema que temos hoje
o problema é que milhões de toneladas de
lixo só isso
entulho plásticos jogados e anos com 105
correntes rotatórias espalhadas por
todos os mares
o mais importante é esse caso nada disso
mudará até 2050 teremos mais próximo do
que textos em nossos oceanos
vou falar agora para vocês sobre essa
inovação seu neo ocean clineu rei que
fica a raiclin oceano
ela foi criada pelo jovem estudante de
engenharia holandês de 19 anos em 2012
em poeta e também criou a fundação the
ocean clipper quando ela funciona alegou
um filtro gigante que recolhe todo o
material plástico que flutua nos oceanos
mares
ela pode ser usada em mares muito
poluídos com a cinco correntes
rotatórias em que eu falei
depois de recolhido o lixo e tratado
corretamente quais os benefícios que os
mais benefícios são que ela promete
acabar com inês de lixo principalmente
existentes no oceano pacífico em apenas
cinco anos
portanto de poluição que a gente os
oceanos é pouco
consequentemente isso preserva os peixes
e as aves
conclusão ninguém deve jogar a gente em
qualquer lugar não sei se o próprio
local de coleta também concluímos que
pequenas ações de cada um de nós pode
mudar o rumo do planeta
obrigado